I grow slogan here is there's no such
thing as a $10,000 tomato medical
marijuana is big business in California
there are several hundred thousand
medical marijuana patients in the state
and pot entrepreneurs are working hard
to meet the ever-increasing demand to
learn more about the marijuana
cultivation business we went to Oakland
Californians spoke to the people at I
gripped the first hydroponic superstore
in the United States I grow is a 15,000
square foot retail store that's open in
January of 2010 and we basically are you
know not hiding in the dark hydroponic
retail service to where you can come in
and watch the consult with you and
discuss you growing your medical
marijuana well my name is Zeta sette and
I'm the senior technician here at I grow
and basically I go and do consultations
I build do installations anywhere from
the smallest level to the commercial
level I also design and build different
state of the art grow rooms in different
state of the art systems here in Oakland
at I grow okay this is where it all
really starts because you have your you
grow up your mom plants and then you
take these cuttings we take these
cuttings you stick them in cloning gel
and then you stick them in these little
neoprene collars now these neoprene
collars they actually hold the stem in
place okay and then you set it on top of
here and you'll have like it I don't
like an inch of stem underneath there
and they've creates the perfect routing
of arm because it's nice to humid and on
the top you won't have any more problems
like you do with domes or anything like
that so it's not lots of air going on
the top so it produces clothes every
eight to ten days this is what's called
a grow tent here it's got this silver
lining called mylar and basically we
have a four by four tray in here with a
thousand watt light over top of it
there's a reservoir down here that that
fills up this tray and what this system
is called is called an ebb and flow
system basically it's it's coin from the
tides of the ocean and so it fills up
feeds the plants and then drains back
down for this type of system here I
would say if I was gonna do see a green
impact 20 of them in here and have like
high intensity lighting I would probably
Bank on like 2 ounces per plant a
package like this will cost anywhere you
know with it with the light the tray and
the grid say anywhere between like a
thousand to twelve hundred dollars
which a return on that is way much more
we also have a trim machine here too as
well this trim machine is a pretty
elaborate trim machine you basically
don't have to do any trimming at all you
just take your plant you put it through
there and it separates everything it
separates your your keifa separates your
leaves and it comes out with a final
product with very little manual
manicuring at the end so it actually
takes place out of 20 trimmers the
cutting system is actually twelve
thousand dollars for this only because
it's a really elaborate system i grow is
obviously the place to go if you want to
grow medical marijuana but what if you
want to grow a lot of medical marijuana
and you want to do it discreetly without
working very hard
well i grow has actually teamed up with
grow up technologies to produce 53 foot
forty foot and 20 foot modular grow
units and what these are are semi truck
trailers that are completely outfitted
as a gross space to where we drop them
off to you and it's a plug-and-play
turnkey system to where you just add
water and hookup electricity's and
you're good to grow that system that a
design is pretty unbelievable it's it's
really nice as a turnkey solution it's
it's very good for for pretty much
anybody that's that's starting growing
whether you're the novice or whether
you're the advanced user we make it to
where it's completely idiot-proof
currently our standards are eighteen
lights Evan flow system with a separate
room for cloning mothering as well as
many upgrades available as well and
customizable to your growing needs
certain upgrades are security systems
and and totally integrated monitoring to
where you can actually from your iPhone
control your pH balance as well as view
your grow as it happens the 53 footers
are starting at 70,000 without the
upgrades some of the customers that
we've sold it to you have yield anywhere
between thirty and forty pounds out of
this thing okay let's get this straight
the trailer cost seventy thousand
dollars and you can produce around
thirty pounds every few months if you
can sell a pound for around three
thousand bucks then you're making a
profit
after your very first harvest those of
you watching this who don't live in
Oakland may be wondering how the
Auckland City Council can allow a place
like I grow to open up shop in their
City Oakland has been from the very
beginning of medical marijuana been the
epicenter of everything you know it was
the first place actually have the
dispensaries here and you know the City
Council and legislation or Oakland has
been really for the
the medical marijuana industry as well
so they're really for it at our grand
opening we had council members here at a
ribbon-cutting ceremony so what's next
for the City of Oakland the Oakland City
Council just recently approved last week
allowing for permitted large
cultivations
in Oakland which is groundbreaking for
the City of Oakland and it's been
legislation that's been been been kind
of organized in the past year and what
it'll allow for Oakland is that actually
regulates and tax cultivation of medical
marijuana it's going on right now you
know and it's going on illegally and
it's going on everywhere but you know
they wanted the City of Oakland wants to
be able to permit it and be able to
control it more you know all the way
from seed to two harvests to patient
consumption and how we're getting
involved is we're actually a dar man and
Derek Peterson the two co-founders of
Gro Peck are going after one of the
permits for that we're a group of
entrepreneurs that are going after this
permit because we just want to do
something great for the medical
marijuana industry as well as for the
City of Oakland you know we plan to give
back in as much as twenty million
dollars in philanthropies and grants in
the City of Oakland to help different
community organizations as well as the
taxes I'm actually the one of the
designers of one of these facilities
we're designing it like eco-friendly
very green of course you know with lots
of different state-of-the-art technology
to be able to make it to where it runs
you know perfectly and smoothly dream
come true for you yeah absolutely and
yeah I mean I think it's a great stuff
fort I really do I mean like it's gonna
be a model for the rest of the country
City of Oakland has really done
something great by passing that
legislation what if you want to get
involved in the industry but you don't
have a green thumb
not to worry I grow is rebranding the
company as we grow and franchising
opportunities are available now for
reason TV I'm Paul five
[Music]